Rebecca Bogart is a senior at Marjory
Stoneman Douglas High School in parkland
Florida she was inside a classroom where
the windows were shot out during the
rampage and she joins us tonight Rebecca
thanks for joining us what did you hear
I was in class in the freshman building
and I heard I heard gunshots and I
didn't know what your react because I
wasn't sure what that was yes and it was
like we just automatically knew when we
hear that just to go in hiding because
we no one in my class ever heard that
before so we all automatically went in
hid under the teacher's desk what did
your teacher do when the shots began my
teacher usually the teacher note that
first we thought it was a drill and
usually the teachers know if this is a
drill and she just like look concerned
so we're all like trying to stay calm
hiding most of the class try to fit
behind your desk and there was ten kids
on the other side by the computer cart
kind of near the window and the teacher
she had her phone we're staying there
for a while and then she was on her
walking and talking administration and
she was on the phone with the police and
we all stayed calm just like try to
relax because no one really knew what
was happening how long did the shots go
on would you say
for a while I feel like 10 minutes we
heard at first and we're hiding and then
we knew it was real when we saw the
bullets the shots go through the window
and glass shattered everywhere and a
couple kids in my class got hit what did
what did where were you I was hiding
with the teacher and a couple of
students like by her desk like hiding
away from the window where the students
in your class badly injured I don't know
how bad it was hard to see but when I
saw them leaving there just a lot of
blood and they were pretty calm about it
but it was just like really traumatic to
watch it gosh that is just awful
did did you know about the man accused
of doing this I do not we had you heard
his name or were you aware of him
I heard his name before bye didn't know
I think he worked out one of the local
stores here so when I saw the picture of
him I know he looked kind of familiar
but know much about him what kind of
store is it the dollar store the dollar
store interesting did you all have you
gone through drills for a situation like
this yeah we were pretty prepared we
know too high like stay away from
windows and everything but we were
trying to do that but once though the
bullets went through the window and the
glass shattered we knew it was like the
real thing that this is not a drill or
anything and when people got hit they
were screaming they're in panic mode
they didn't know what to do so we try to
keep everyone quiet like fascism like as
quick as we can
we wanted everyone remain calm at the
time I didn't know that any students
were shot so and then someone told me my
classroom is sitting next to me but the
bullets were extremely loud nothing I
ever heard oh did you text your parents
from the classroom
I didn't have my phone at the time but
my parents knew so afterwards the the
SWAT came and they asked how many people
were injured or yeah if there's any
deaths or injuries so we told them and
how many students I think there was
about thirty students in our class so
then we all had a we all lined up one by
one
walked out we had to run as far as we
can and we all had to stay calm is
really hard watching everyone people
were crying there was a lot of blood
everywhere
leaving the hallway looking on the floor
seeing blood and just like kids just
such a scary thought when did your
parents find out you were okay once I
left my backpack and everything is down
class right now my car's there my keys I
just grabbed my phone and ran and my mom
called me a bunch of times I wasn't
answering so she was worried but then I
called her I was walking away and I was
with a bunch of kids so I felt like safe
and just walk as far as it can you're so
calm right now I can't imagine seeing
something like that how do you feel yeah
me before I was like shaking the entire
time I was shaking but now like I'm
still in shock right now it's just like
unbelievable to actually think this
happen here at Stoneman Douglas it's
have you ever felt threatened there
before
no never but I know that the staff
trained us is really going to training
us for like anything a tornado drill
hurricane drill yeah especially this so
I think everyone reacted good and the
teachers had the door locks so that was
good
was your teacher calm the whole time my
teacher was pretty calm yeah she was on
the phone she was like being quiet on
the phone so her being calm kept us all
calm but we're all like there for each
other we're all like cuddled up together
holding hands what a what a horrifying
horrifying experience you've lived
through Rebecca Bogart thanks a lot for
sharing that with us thank you